we start today with Jennifer Aniston for
decades she was plagued with questions
about having kids well now Jennifer is
revealing the brutal truth behind her
struggle to get pregnant
quote all the years and years and years
of speculation it was really hard I was
going through IVF drinking Chinese teas
you name it we can do it all we're
sleeping we're 80.
all right babe and the narrative that my
husband left me because I wouldn't give
him a kid it was absolute lies
nearly 20 years after Jen and Brad split
she is speaking her truth inside a lure
because quote I don't have anything to
hide at this point at 53 Jen says she is
at peace with her fertility struggles
quote I would have given anything if
someone had said to me freeze your eggs
so here I am today the ship has sailed
so many of my friends have been through
it of struggled with fertility it's an
excruciating situation for people
sometimes back in 2004 Jen poked fun at
the incessant gossip on SNL
but in 2016 Jen reached her tabloid
Tipping Point when in touch published
this shot pointing out a possible
pregnancy while on vacation with then
husband Justin throw
a picture of me with a bump and a circle
around my stomach I was
just fed up with it Jen then penned a
scathing 873-word essay for HuffPost
saying quote I am not pregnant what I am
is fed up I'm a tabloid nightmare like
people my life seems so much more
dramatic and because of the stupid
tabloids and now with this not safe for
work cover shot Jen proudly says this is
what it looks like to be fierce fearless
and unapologetically feeling herself
while Jen told the Lord she does not
rule out getting married again she's
loving where her life is at quote I feel
better than I ever did in my 20s or 30s
even or my mid-40s I looked bleeping
great at 53.
[Music]